the concept of visibility is arguably
the most important concept you need to
understand in order to advance your
career so welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel firm learning
my name is Heineken on my Channel I want
to help you to become successful in the
first years of your career and today we
are going to talk about visibility
before we get started I want to thank
the sponsor of today's video this is
Allianz Consulting Alliance Consulting
is hiring for several open positions
you'll find a link to their careers page
in the video description so what is
visibility all about and the first time
I really had an eye-opening moment about
this was in one of my earlier interviews
as a young student I was working on site
in that company and suddenly I realized
that the colleagues were getting a
little bit more nervous there were some
certain atmosphere in the office and I
was a bit unsure what is it what is
causing this and so I I got in contact
with some of the people I asked them and
then I found out that actually it was
promotion season so it was the season of
the year where the candidates where the
different colleagues in the company were
being discussed were being evaluated by
the people processes that were in place
to then make the decision will get the
promotion and of course also who will
not get the promotion and in this
context I suddenly overheard a
conversation that some of these people
had and these people were talking to
each other about another person that was
in another team and I overheard one
person saying something like oh this
person is not visible enough this person
is not visible enough which is why this
person will likely not get promoted
visibility this is what I want to talk
about with you in this video I will talk
about what it actually is why it matters
and what you can do to increase is your
visibility and thereby also fast track
your career the key fallacy that is
behind all of this is the thought that
people have in their minds that if they
just do a great job every single day if
this is the only thing that they do then
they will get noted they will get
promoted they will have a successful
career and this is a mindset that people
adopt from leaving high school maybe
even from going to University well of
course there's a link between your
immediate performance the time you put
in to study and then the results the
exam grades the exam results and so on
this link is much more established but
this is a fallacy after all everyone
knows there's a trust will just spent a
couple of years in corporate this is a
fallacy this is not how it works and to
understand this it is important to think
about how the promotion the designation
processes work and I'd argue this is
very similar doesn't matter better
whether you work in Consulting and
Professional Services or whether you
work in a corporate environment maybe
the details differ but in the end of the
day how it works is that one or two
times a year usually these people
committees come together the HR
Community comes together to then
evaluate and assess individual employees
and check who's ready for a designation
but how exactly does this work usually a
more senior leader of that organization
and a consulting firm these are usually
the partners the senior partners and
corporate these are some senior business
unit leaders they put together a case
for the people who are being discussed
and are up for promotion so they will
collect information from the different
departments from the direct supervisors
the team leads that work together with
these people
they will connect interviews collect
info look at the last evaluation sheets
and so on and based on that they will
present this to the committee and make a
suggestion whether this person should be
designated or not and then all of there
is some discussion going on of course
many people maybe would like to see
their candidates designated but usually
not every person can get designated and
this is how it works so think about what
this implies well this implies is that
very often it is not your direct
supervisor who will then stand in this
committee and make the case for you it
might not be the people in your team or
maybe also in some other teams you very
closely worked with but often there will
be someone else someone much more senior
one or two or three levels above these
people will then make the case for you
so these are people whom you are not in
direct contact with maybe you have never
even seen these people maybe these
people have never even seen you right
and this of course is a big issue now
try to put yourself into the shoes of
one of these senior people who needs to
present the case to the committee let's
say they have two candidates on their
table right so the one person working in
the one team got great reviews from the
direct supervisor from the team lead but
this senior leader has never ever seen
that person has never personally
interacted with this person and now that
person also reviews a second candidate
very similar reviews this candidate got
from the team leader from the other
peers but this is a candidate that the
senior leader has been working with very
closely over the last months or years
that is a person who has been very
visible to this senior leader what do
you think who has higher chances of
getting promoted of getting designated
in the next review cycle both candidates
have very similar very comparable
performance reviews but still the one
person is visible and the other person
is not visible to the people who then
indeed make the decision in the end I
trust it is not surprising at all that
it will be the more visible person has
the higher chances of being promoted
this leads me to a saying that is very
common in business and this is
perception is reality perception is
reality maybe you did an excellent job
you're exceeding all the expectations
that were expressed towards your role
you were going above and beyond of what
was required from you but what if no one
knows about it what if no one has the
perception that this is what you are
doing then arguably it's worthless right
it doesn't matter you didn't do anything
for what's that worth so you always need
to think about what are the perceptions
that your actions are creating a term
that is often used in this context is
perception management especially if you
have a career in corporate Consulting
Professional Services and so on at some
point you need to think about how to
manage perceptions of your peers of your
clients of your colleagues of your
supervisors you need to become good at
perception management and of course in
most situations there will be quite a
tight relationship with between your
performance and the perception that is
getting created about your performance
but this is not always the case right
and you hear this all the time that
people complain that someone else took
the credit for his or her work that
something didn't go the right way the
people are not taking notice of the
merits of the results of the impact that
you are creating to hear stories like
this all the time this is in the end
what it always comes down to perception
is reality and of course then also the
question whose perception just the
perception of your team lead is this the
only person who knows about what you did
or does the senior leader nobody as well
and has also this perception that yes
this person this team is a high
performer this is a rock star someone
that really created significant impact
for the organization
right now I'm standing here on the
rooftop Terrace of Allianz in the heart
of Munich big big thanks to Allianz for
supporting the work here on from
learning by sponsoring this video
Alliance Consulting is currently growing
quite rapidly among their locations
across the world so if you are
interested in a new opportunity in
in-house Consulting in strategy
Consulting I.T business operations or
any other roads like that I will link
the alliance career page in the video
description feel free to check it out I
trust there are many opportunities out
there for you to grow both
professionally and personally but now
let's continue with the video so what
can you do to increase your visibility
at work and let me share five tips that
hopefully you find actionable and
helpful first strategically think about
the interactions you are going to have
in this week and next week and so on now
in a Consulting context for instance
very often the partner is coming in once
per week maybe one day of the week and
having this one 90 minutes meeting with
your partner or maybe the senior
Partners only coming in every second or
every third week right so often it's
just very few interactions that you can
have throughout the course of a project
of an engagement that very much shape
the impression that this person has
about you so what you better make sure
is that it in these 90 minutes that you
have with that person or maybe only
these one or two meetings every month
you're having with the senior partner
you make that count right so you are
making sure that first you have maybe a
certain role in this meeting so if
you're politically smart this might be
something you might be able to align
with your team lead hey what is the
section of the meeting maybe you can
lead you can drive you are responsible
for for to avoid that you are just the
person or sitting in the meeting room
not saying anything it's smart to think
about what are some topics that you want
to raise what are some questions you
want to ask how do you want to say
certain things very few interactions
with these senior leaders often in a
very significant way impact the
perception that these people have about
you so make sure that these interactions
count second clearly communicate your
successes this of course starts with
first you're having a clear
understanding what your successes are
but then second also communicating them
and this might be in your weekly
one-on-ones you're having with your
direct supervisor to make sure that you
are also going over the topics you
completed last week what the result was
what the impact was not only talking
about some issues or maybe the next
steps for the next weeks you're having
another technique very commonly applied
in Consulting and I'd say very helpful
for other roles as well our end of week
emails so will be very common for
project leads sometimes even senior
Associates to write a summary of the
week at the end of the week highlighting
first the highlights so what happened
what has been achieved second the low
lights what are maybe also some
obstacles you're facing things that the
team needs to overcome and third what
are the next steps right that you are
facing in the next week third engage
yourself in activities beyond your
day-to-day job so what can you do on top
of what you're doing anyways right so
this might be organizing a team event a
team dinner maybe this might be engaging
yourself in office activities maybe an
organizing an office event organizing
some charity work that is led by the
office often these types of initiatives
are also sponsored by Partners senior
Partners senior leaders in your
organization so this is usually a great
opportunity to work together with one of
these people fourth be mindful of how
you say things many people tend to
always say we we did this we did that we
achieved this we are achieve that and of
course from a team perspective that's
understandable rarely it was only
yourself to do something often it was a
teamwork right but still I think it's
very fair game to also highlight your
contribution what did you do what was
your impact that you had that's very
similar advice that you also often hear
when you write your CVS right always
make sure to not only highlight the team
accomplishments but also your individual
contribution to what has happened but
this of course I do not mean that you
should take away the spotlight from your
team or that you should take credit for
work that you didn't do of course be
ethical but within the things that you
really did do make sure that you also
take the credit for what happened and
for what your impact was in the
situation Point number five this is
maybe an unpopular opinion so I really
hate to break it to you but even back in
the days it was considered conventional
wisdom that if you want to Fast Track
and Advance your career it's usually a
good idea to be close to the headquarter
to ideally work in the headquarter
compared to maybe some remote other
locations some remote other business
unit or country organization the reason
being that of course the closer you are
to headquarter the closer you are to the
senior leaders to the board members to
the business unit heads to the decision
makers right and of course this to some
extent still holds true today of course
it depends on the company culture if it
is a completely virtual organization
even the senior leaders are never to be
seen anywhere besides some video calls
and this might not be the case but often
hey most organizations there is an
office and surprise surprise in most
organizations the senior leaders they
don't do five days a week home office
but they tend to be in the office a bit
more often a bit more frequently and so
this is a great opportunity to go to the
office as well meet people interact with
people increase your visibility ability
and I'm very sure that if you look into
most companies and you look at what are
the people they get promoted what are
the people that are not getting promoted
probably there will be some interesting
studies and Academia about this in the
next years but I'm pretty sure that if
you are in the office and make yourself
visible this will definitely not hurt
your chances of advancing your career
and getting designated I know that not
everyone sees it that way feel free to
disagree with me leave a comment in the
comment section and share your opinion
with the community so if you took any
value out of this video at all please
destroy the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and of course subscribe to the
channel if you want to stay up to date
on my content big big thanks to all the
members of the channel and of course
also to the sponsor of this week's video
Allianz Consulting Alliance is hiring
for many roads around the world you will
find a link to their careers page in the
video description be free to check it
out my name is Heinrich I'm releasing
weekly videos here on this channel see
you again next Saturday all best to you
and bye bye